[Music]
I don't forgot who someone tweeted this
picture it's this old lady at a [__]
hockey game and she's got her font size
on
88 and it says Mike just died and she
responds well
crap
did we ever talk about this I was on
some flight
and a lady had you know font size
6000 texting her daughter about a guy
next to her that she's like cute guy
sitting next to me I'm going to flirt
with him you know and she's got her
[__] quad focals on trying to read
the
text you're reading this I can you
couldn't miss it okay she may as well
have held an iPad up be like over her
chair and so she she's sitting in front
of me on the plane and I can see through
the chair to and I couldn't not be nosy
yeah yeah right you know I just look up
and I see cute guy next to me and I go
how's this going to pan out yeah yeah
and then she's texting her daughter
about him and then she's going to suck
his dick yeah yeah I'm going to suck and
[__] him till he dies I'm GNA die on his
[__] sweetie I'm so old I'm going to die
on this big dick I know it's huge I'm
going to let him kill me with his [__]
jesus
I let him murder my [__] with his C I
wouldn't put it past an old person on
their phone yeah yeah like it's always
like the pictures that I see are
always yeah like dudes like this that
are always like I'm going to [__]
punish you when I get home it's like
what does that [__] say yeah yeah I can
eat your [__] and [__]
you
raw he was not discreet about that no
not at all look at that guy and then he
just locks his phone and puts it back in
next to his kid next to his kid that's
what I mean they're always just the
sickest [__] these people are
freaks I want to eat your [__] from the
back what' you say honey Al sorry
randomly took a flight this weekend one
of the guys with us he was trying to
sleep on the way back and he said he
described it as he said dude these two
people next to me they must not have
seen each other in years and they must
have wanted to [__] because they like it
was they yapping yeah but it was
flirting yeah really and he was just
there on the window
just oh my God so uncomfortable oh my
God stop it stop it no I'm serious you
look great in that
shirt oh my God you need to stop but
what what no but like would you would
you ever do the mile high club thing or
like like I'm like you never done it
have you what if they were all and just
being dis yeah yeah yeah I was
suck I would suck your boobs so hard
right now I want to lick on your nipples
that's how old people flirt yeah right
there yeah just weird [__] some [__]
might happen you
know like someone hits the garbage
disposal and [__] get you know something
disappears in there it's like oh [__]
thought it was your mom in there yeah a
dad as truth that's why I'm marit her
God damn it that
neck I wait till my kids are 25 and just
tear teriz them with that just be eating
Thanksgiving dinner I'll be like
God this turkey reminds me of your
mom getting in here just makes me think
of when we were young you know I used to
get down on it just like this yeah and I
would just
[__] it's like I think like the kids
like walk in the
kitchen as the dad's watching the mom
like base the turkey he's like that
reminds reminds me of us and she's like
Daryl stop oh no yeah no no no give me
give me the Bas give Bas oh I wish I did
not hear that give me the baser what if
I just squirt a little on the face huh
the face of the turkey just like
that tfue think I [__] up friend
caught me sniffing his Elder sister's
panties panties why you say Elder like
that this guy was born in [__] 60
yeah his Elder sisters panties was
chilling at my friend's house and we
both got hungry so we decided to order
some food his parents didn't allow us to
order food ourselves uh FSR
FSR for sir some reason for sir sir for
some reason okay yeah apparently we
weren't old enough we were 15 and so we
had to do it through his sister who was
18 so she ordered the food and
everything and it was picked up so she
went God damn it you cannot tell a story
and it was a pickup like a pickup order
yeah I know but just like so she ordered
the food and everything it was pickups
she just went to pick up the food in her
car which she was was driving with her
two hands while we stayed at the home
playing the video games in the living
room on the couch in the kitchen next to
the couch I had to go to the toilet and
the only one free was the upstairs one
which was different from the downstairs
one cuz it was upstairs and now once I
entered the toilet through the door the
laundry basket was in there with dirty
clothes and it was meant to be outside
but it was inside the upstairs bathroom
which is different from the downstairs
bathroom cuz it's
upstairs and so I decided to take it out
on myself and carry I took out the
laundry myself cuz it was inside the
upstairs bathroom and I carried it out
of the bathroom I walked outside with it
and accidentally dropped it all because
when I scrambled to pick it all up I saw
some pant dude you're telling on
yourself bro seriously this is so fake
too yeah like as in like the story might
be real but like this part of it is fake
I just yeah oh I was I thought I'd be a
Good Samaritan and take out the laundry
myself so like yeah you know I was just
I was in this sticky situation just
purely by coincidence because I was
being a good person and I was taking the
poop I didn't want the poop to stin up
the clothes the bathroom and the clothes
yeah so you know I took the clothes out
and then and I [__] dropped them lo
and behold some panties fell on the
ground not
normally you know but I felt bad her I
don't want her to be embarrassed cuz the
panties were on the ground so I picked
them up I sniffed
them to see if they smelled like my poop
just to make sure just cuz if they did I
would have felt really bad I would have
washed for her dude this guy says me
being me I grabbed them and inspected
them thinking if they were his mom's or
sister oh he's
English ah creep you
pevet creepy P me being me I grabbed
them and inspect you bro you can't
preface with me being me that's what I'm
saying wait let's finish the sentence me
being me I grabbed them and inspected
them thinking if they were his moms or
sisters and I thought whatever and got
really horny and started sniffing them I
love I thought it was going to be an
excuse like me being me you know I
wanted to smell the pantties or I wanted
to pick up the panties and just see like
oh if it's his mom's maybe I can tease
him for it like it's a thong man your
mom wears thongs but he was like me
being me I'm a sick [__] perv so I
just started yeah you know me being me I
start looking for
residue you know me being I'm a [__]
Truffle Pig for
discharge oh my god dude oh my
[Laughter]
god I didn't even realize at this point
he was coming up upstairs to check why I
was talking why I was taking so long and
when I looked up my jaw dropped and the
underwear fell out of my
mouth the next five minutes we just
stood in silence and eventually he just
walked down he got so mad and I
apologized for so long what if he was
like those are my panties
yeah and and but made him promise he
wouldn't tell his mom or sister but keep
it between us now that secret remain
Still Remains of them but that was a
horrible day for me we haven't talked
about it much but I'd rather forget
about it bro come on man it's just me
being me why you being weird I'm just
being Miley well you can't dude you
can't get mad at me for doing me yeah
I'm just doing just doing me bro I'm
just sniffing other people's underwear
cuz it's what I do it's me being
me